good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday it is hump
day the most important and sort of vital
day here at the toast hey Jax how you
doing I'm doing well I'm glad that
you're speaking to the importance of
hump day because not only is it vital to
the toast like it's vital to the world
population like if we ain't humping we
ain't procreating and if Humanity could
cease to humanity could go extinct
without hump day if we ain't humping we
ain't jumping
well that's true because it rhymes
exactly yeah
um happy Wednesday everyone it is a
gorgeous day here in New York and
Florida I'm assuming it is it's so
freezing I don't know if it's just my
house but like it has been colder here
and then when it's cold here my house
gets so cold like my heat doesn't work
and we've just kind of given up until
like Frosty I brought out my blanket
today because I just have a chill see
the Snowman by the way our house is so
weird because like me and Ben no matter
what time of year we sleep in a tundra
like but you know we have people come to
the house and when I'm in the living
room eating dinner I don't need to be
freezing so our like living dining
kitchen main living areas are like set
at the heat 80 degrees you open the door
to our bedroom Igloo it's like 59
degrees it's freezing we've never turned
the air off in our bedroom it's two
different I'm living in the North and
South Pole that's not very green of you
mclared oh
you know what I don't want the pressure
of being a green girl like yesterday's
episode was hilarious but you know what
I just want to say like on my part I'm
not gonna speak for Jackie I was joking
like I don't want to be a green girl
like I care about the environment for
sure but I don't want to categorize
myself as a green girl because then I'll
do something and people will be like
really Claudia you could have walked it
was only two blocks but you know what
I'm tired and you're not a green girl so
but I'm not a green girl so I don't want
that expectation being put on me you
know what I mean I understand I
understand I already put so much
pressure on myself like I didn't choose
this life is the thing like it kind of
chose me that Tesla chose me and I'm
doing what I look at my cup today you
guys
oh my God now you're listening is a
podcast for the first time in six
seasons Jackie is drinking her coffee
out of a mug not
a plastic cup well and straw I used to
always drink hot coffee and I'm drinking
a hot coffee today because I stated I'm
chilly uh but when we would do the toast
in New York I had to take my hot coffee
on the road hence you know a disposable
cup but now that I'm in my house
drinking out of my mug like I have a mug
so I have a mug and I have a Tesla like
who is she and by the way yesterday uh
Greta tunberg was actually detained by
German forces for protesting in a coal
mine so it seems like she's gonna be out
of commission for a bit and the the
spotlight for like a new famous green
girly is empty and it sounds like granny
a temporary replacement me the only
thing is with that my wires are crossing
because I support the toonies but I
support the coal miners yeah no I want
to know what she was uh what she was was
she protesting the miners because you
come for the miners I come for you she
was protesting coal mining in general
because like it emits greenhouse gases
that are bad for the environment but
like
that's a tough one for me no yeah
because it's like do we where do we care
more about the gas is being emitted from
the coal mining or coal miners working
hard providing for their families and I
think what they mine like creates we
need everything yeah like I'm not 100
they're not doing it for fun for fun no
it's like that's a really important [ __ ]
and it's like a job nobody wants and
it's like the lowest totem pole so I'm
gonna stick with the coal miners because
I support here in America like I support
hard-working people the men and women of
coal mining Industries supporting their
families and they're really the backbone
of this nation and for how how much we
talk about them I really should learn
like what coal miners do like what are
they mining where does the coal go I
feel like the coal makes like energy
yeah they're mining coal and then we use
that cold and like burn that cold to
create Fuel and a bunch of other things
that keep us running sounds like it's
it's a no-brainer like we need the coal
miners Greta they're okay
girl boss a little too close to the Sun
on that the pictures of her getting
arrested well not arrested they said
detained I don't know what the
difference she was like walked off this
set yeah um did you see there's a video
so the pictures of her went viral
because she's in the arms of like four
big German detainees and she's just
chilling they're holding her limb by
limb one for her arm one for her other
arm one for her leg one for her other
leg and she's just chilling like not
bothered and it looks like this like
triumphant photo
and then I saw a video of it and it
wasn't as triumphant and there was like
a guy being like Greta can I get a
selfie with you and she's like like for
a while she's just like standing there
with the police officers like nothing's
really happening they're just like
taking pictures it was
it was giving photo up it was but that's
I don't know what Greta lives for no and
the green girlies we can't turn on each
other you know no no we can't but like
you came for the coal miners Greta
I know and I don't know how we can
support you I draw the line I draw the
line I do minors also like doesn't she
have to go to school
I've often wondered that about Greta
tune but here's the thing about the
great Greta
is that when she first popped on the
scene everyone was like Shook and she
was like 16. that was like six years ago
really now yeah okay because I also then
part of me like feels weird even talking
about her because I'm like she's 12. a
child she's not I think she's in her 20s
now she's 20. okay
so she's different
doesn't need she probably has her High
School degree it's also different like
in Germany College yeah is she German
I thought she was like what accent is
this how dare you
[Laughter]
I thought she was like Swedish
no I feel like she's Dutch
she is from Sweden oh okay she's got
that Icelandic but no not Icelandic what
um Nordic Nordic yeah
I swear I thought she was German well it
was confusing because like then she was
in Germany yesterday
right right doing protesting like
they're coal miners like right like you
don't know German culture Greta
stay out of it no one thing about Greta
she's not gonna stay out of it she's
gonna make it her business yeah and
that's why she's as successful as she
was and why she is and that's why she
was time woman of the year like when she
was four time Girl of the Year uh that's
also why she and I had to cancel our
lunch plans
um but now things are kind of like a
little awkward with us just because she
knows where I stand about the coal
miners the coal miners yeah and like and
then she now has a problem with me so I
don't know what the Korean Community is
for me I think the green girlies like
might be breaking up yeah there's just a
lot of wires and everybody you know like
everybody has their
their agenda yeah I'm bowing out I don't
want to be a green girly it's too much
pressure I want to continue to care
about the environment but care about
myself a little bit more
and and do that in peace but that's why
driving a Tesla is so perfect because
you get to be like inadvertently green
and you like look sickening and like a
futuristic robot oh my God you know I
did take an Uber to the studio today
even though it's walkable I was just so
tired uh and I got a test
my boots are gonna spare it no and I
didn't admit any you know
greenhouse gases emissions
carbon emissions yeah like it wasn't it
wasn't bad for the environment for me to
take an Uber today that's good yeah
that's really good so all in all are you
supportive of me getting a Tesla there
was like 70 Whispers that you didn't
seem supportive you know actually I
wanted to talk about that yesterday
because I was FaceTiming with two of my
friends yesterday I was probably in just
all day like one of the worst moods one
of those [ __ ] moods and I was free
watching the show yesterday and as I was
doing the show yesterday I was like I
knew I had like a mug on my face and
like I just didn't [ __ ] care so I
actually did want to apologize to you
and to everyone like I just was in like
a [ __ ] nasty ass mood yesterday and I
was trying I was like
and like I didn't notice the um I was I
was literally in such a bad I got such
bad sleep the night before last like I
was in such a bad mood and I'm feeling
better today so now I can acknowledge
that I was wrong like I was just like if
you watched my face yesterday especially
at the beginning after like 10 or 15
minutes even if you're in a bad mood the
toast brings you out of it but in the
beginning I was like a mean Muggin
yesterday got it got it but like aside
from the bad mood like I I feel like
there's a part of you that's just like
not Vince about me getting a Tesla okay
don't be paranoid I'm very convinced oh
okay cool what's wrong why would you
please wanted to send me to a charging
station
okay
I see what you mean I'm just I want you
to be thinking it through you know like
I just want you to know all the
different you know responsibilities that
come along and I'm cheap I'm like where
can we go get free chocolates you know
free energy free energy and I'm sorry if
that made it seem like I wasn't
supportive I'm just I'm trying to think
of all possible scenarios you know got
it okay cool cool I'm glad that you're
excited and I just know when you come
down here like we're gonna be I'm gonna
go around my Whip and you're gonna be
obsessed I will say
I have been driven in a Tesla by like
friends two times once by Lauren
Elizabeth and one's actually not to brag
by Ryan Phillippe and both times the one
thing I didn't like about the car and
you don't drive fast so like I'm not
worried about that
is when you like go from like you know
standing to driving fast like there's
such a yeah it's like if you hit the gas
like you're everyone was flying you know
Kyle Busch
it was a NASCAR yes it's like room and
like your hair like you get pulled back
yeah that's like supposed to be a perk
but you know that would be me I no do
not feel the need for speed now let's
just circle back
the car ride with Ryan Phillippe yeah
one time he drove me uh to a party just
you and him no no the car was full but
it felt like it was just me and him what
seat were you in uh I was behind he was
driving and I was behind him in the back
seat that's not so bad at least you
weren't like in the backpack no no but I
wasn't you know his passenger was a
shotgun no I wasn't shotgun I was
sitting right behind Ryan that's pretty
cool was he a good driver
yeah
what kind of Tesla do you remember
oh it had the doors that go up it was
actually really sick yes model X it was
really sick it's pretty cool it's about
mobile yeah it was a Batmobile I think
it was white I really can't remember
I didn't know that story so that's a
cool story one thing about me is I am an
endless well of thirsty stories like
that's just me if there's a celebrity
involved like I'm gonna tell it but you
haven't told that one it hasn't come up
it makes you wonder like what else
we don't know about you I know I feel
like actually I'm so braggadocious is
that the right word like when you're
braggy yeah okay I'm so braggadocious
like about everything but actually I
feel like a lot of stories I have with
celebrities I actually keep close to the
vest because one you won't get anybody
back I won't get invited back and like
two you never know like how celebrities
feel like some some like it some don't
like I don't know so I just like shut my
mouth yeah I understand I feel like
there's a statute of limitation and then
you could tell the story yes
understood we look forward to hearing
about what happened in La for real
speaking about 10 years literally
thinking about no speaking about things
that I'm looking forward to today's like
a really big day Jackie and I decided
we've had this idea for a while and we
weren't sure exactly how to do it from a
technology technology standpoint but we
figured it out with the help of YouTube
tonight we've been wanting to do a live
show like a digital virtual live show on
our patreon forever we like fig we
looked into a bunch of different
platforms and we figured out the best
way to do it is on YouTube we think
tonight is our first one so if you're a
patreon member you already know but if
you aren't a patreon member you've been
thinking about becoming a patreon member
um or this just sounds exciting to you
it's not too late to sign up so today at
five o'clock Eastern time Jackie and I
are doing our first YouTube live show
Jacks from Florida Studio me from my
house we're gonna be doing cocktails pop
culture chit chatting Greta tunberg
um it's all going to be live so it's
kind of like our old uh Audio Only Live
show with Spotify live breaking bread
we're calling this one freaking Fred
own the name like legally want to get in
trouble sued by Spotify but it'll be
similar it'll be similar as we're
mentioned you know 45 minutes to an hour
Jackson Claude original recipe the live
chat will be back but if you remember
from the old YouTube live days you'll be
able to comment in real time on YouTube
if you can't catch it and you are a
member or you want to become a member
you'll be able to watch it afterwards on
demand but it'll be like exciting to be
there live I'm very excited I'm excited
too I'm excited to see what people have
to say that'll help like inform the
convo we're gonna just talk about pop
culture things ourselves and then you
know late night Jackson Claude not late
crazy early evening things get
wild Jax gets crazy like kind of
delirious like and a worker all day I
keep it together on this show you know
I'm very much like the on the straight
and narrow
after Dark
[ __ ] it's water there's no telling
what'll happen there's no telling so I'm
really excited for that we have been
talking about doing that for a while
everybody loved breaking bread so
they're gonna love freaking Fred
it's
it's kind of gonna like change the world
I think so I really I'm excited to be
live with our our
peeps again yeah the comments always
crack me up it's gonna be really fun so
we will see you there it's not too late
to join if you want to get in on the fun
it's patreon.com toast
um 7.99 is our premium subscription and
you basically get five extra episodes
from Jackson Claude every month that's
Vlogs podcasts video podcasts
um and it's fabulous so there's no
reason not to great and we've actually
recently brought back a segment that we
used to do on this show but it wasn't
right for our show called unburden
yourselves
um we brought it back on patreon and I
think we're gonna start doing it maybe
like once a month because it was so
funny it was um
burden themselves yeah it's been a long
time oh and speaking of today's
Wednesday so we have deer toasters
um and we have one that I actually feel
personally
um like invested in and like offended by
oh okay can't wait you'll see why it's
our second one oh hey can't wait to get
to that um before we get into everything
anything else you want to update the
group on no I literally watched 45
minutes 45 episodes of mini project last
night people say it goes downhill after
season three and they're not wrong but
it's still like a good funny fresh show
it's not like bad nice yeah I started
reading hillbilly elegy I know it had a
big moment a few years ago and it was
made into a really elegy have you heard
of it Hillbilly LG is a movie too like
Amy Adams Glenn Close
um and I thought it would be a good
follow-up for me to demon Copperhead
which was like about Appalachia to you
know it was honestly amazing and the
author you know tempted to write the
great Appalachian novel to like
represent her people and what they've
gone through so I wanted to learn more
so I just had heard of hillbilly elegy
it was on my want to read so I was like
maybe this feels like a good time to
read it it's non-fiction though
um and I'm getting it's a lot of
non-fiction you know what have the
Appalachian people been through pardon
my ignorance I have literally no idea
they've been through a lot and honestly
it has to do with the coal mining like
that they were like the mining
communities and then like the mines went
away and
um now like they're really struggling
with the opioid crisis yeah and it's
just like this cycle of poverty that
like generational poverty that they
can't get out of and they're just like
kind of like they're just like so
disrespected like yeah they get made fun
of they get made fun of like and it's
like in Demon Copperhead he was like we
have TV we see what you're saying like
it's really nice let me ask you another
question that's going to show how dumb I
am where is Appalachia Appalachian
Mountains but it's it's an it's a number
of states so like Okay
um the demon Copperhead was in Virginia
hillbilly elegy is like between Kentucky
and
um
where's the other place that they Ohio
but it's like the Rust Belt it's a lot
of States gotten uh oh my God that's so
sad I don't think I've ever made fun of
Appalachian people but now I'm gonna
look out for it yeah like even just the
word you know hillbilly and those sorts
of words I thought hillbilly was just
like Southerner
it's it's condescending and for sure
it's condescending but I think and
redneck too but I think in
um
country music is like attempting to take
the words back you know yeah well that's
also in Demon Copperhead that's what he
said like you know it's the name that
they call us and then you know you take
your power back by calling it to
yourself but it's right next red letters
Red Dirt yeah but it's still a
disrespect it's a slur but it's like
it's like white trash like white trash
is not a slur but it's like condescence
but it's bad it shouldn't be like use if
we're not going to be using slurry words
yeah but it's not like a hard slur it's
like one level below for sure but like
we've taken out one we've taken out four
levels below that's true like that lizzo
thing like that's what I was just
thinking of spa
Z yeah or I think they said it was eight
like you won't even say it but we're
saying everything else that we're saying
so true so that's like there was a lot
of points made in Demon Copperhead it's
just it was it was so so good and I just
wanted to educate myself further so I
thought hillbilly elegy would be good
also it's in the 200s amount of pages so
that felt right so is Mindy kaling's
novel which I looked up last night that
I will be adding to my list 222.
um but you know so it does take longer
anyway you know what's else is in the
200s yearbook girl with no job the crazy
beautiful life of an Instagram thirst
monster available wherever you get books
audiobooks ebooks and hardcover books
Amazon Barnes and Noble Indie bookstores
check it out
for as much as we talk about reading on
the show like I really don't plug my own
New York Times best-selling novel that
much and we always are getting new
listeners so it's important that you let
them know because like if they tuned in
three weeks ago like they might not know
and that not only that you've wrote a
book like I think a lot of people write
books but that it's a New York Times
bestseller I think and it's important
it's like actually good you know like
it's Gonna Make You Belly Laugh you
might even cry if you've been through
you know there's a lot to talk about
grief
um it's just like the life story of me
and my journey and like it's not trash
like I feel like a lot of people
especially like digital people like
write books just to write books and they
put like charts in there and [ __ ] like
no it's a 240 page novella is it a
novella it's not it's a memoir but it's
also kind of like a romance and I kind
of feel like there's a sequel that's
going to be written it's this will they
won't they of Claudia and Maverick it's
the Maverick Pages like you think that
this book is about like Claudia and
Ben's romance but the underlying subtext
shows the love that otherwise shows
otherwise Maverick is your mysterious
past Claudia
100 percent
so I don't think I don't think the book
is closed on that honestly quite
literally
you should hold on free idea for you
okay you should write a sequel to your
Memoir that is fiction
it's never been done
that is such a good idea yeah I would
need help though I I'd need to have a
co-writer because I've never I don't
have any experience writing fiction
that's why you write about what I know
best and that's myself yeah but you
could also like take some writing
classes I think that would just like
help you learn how to write fiction like
yeah just change your mindset you know
what I mean yeah no by the way that's
like such a good idea
think about it
the crazy and it would be called the
crazy parallel life or like parallel
universe life of an Instagram third
sponsor you're on an influencer trip in
Paris
and you see Maverick
I'm getting emotional that's like it's
so good and you say to your Parisian
influence her friends
that's my ex Maverick you wrote the
story yesterday but I say it's my
ex-husband because it's a parallel
universe like who cares right right
right
love
love and you know what they would call
them in Paris Maverick
and of course it would be smart
oh my god of course I would actually I
would need Tessa Bailey to write it with
me I don't think I could ever actually
write smut write the smut you wish to
see in the world love that that's like
what Rach parcel is doing I Know Rich
parcel has been talking on Tick Tock
about how she is writing a fictional
book and I'm like so excited yeah
I needed to come out it's such a good
idea it is because I feel like she's
like a really influential reader like
when she shares a book like a lot of
people download it like I think she
could sell a lot of books and she's read
a lot I feel like she could she could
get her done
yeah you guys have the same taste in
books right
yeah very similar I've taken a lot of
really good recommendations from her
awesome
maybe she needs a co-writer I might you
could do it together she could just name
her character Maverick
perfect
um all right let's dive in because we've
got your toasters we've got five stories
a gorgeous day for gorgeous girls so
without further uh did it did it do here
are the best size stories that you need
to know
and today's episode is sponsored by
Sundays which I'm excited about a brand
new sponsor for all of our dog moms and
dads out there Sundays is air dried dog
food made from a short list of human
grade ingredients Sundays was co-founded
by Dr Tory who's a practicing
veterinarian so it's really trustworthy
the food actually contains 90 Meat 10
vegetables and zero percent synthetic
nutrients I can speak from experience
Theo is now on his third food his first
two he developed I'm not an allergy but
like an intolerance to could have like
itchy legs or scratchy throat and I've
been on Sundays now for a few months
well I've not been on it sorry Theo's
been on it it's a food for dogs
um and it has had such a made such a
difference Theo loves it
so it's USDA beef all-natural chicken
but you'll also find digestive AIDS like
pumpkin Ginger plus disease fighting
antioxidants so dog parents have
reported noticeable Health improvements
in their pups including softer fur
fresher breath better poops and more
energy Theo is loving it I've definitely
seen like major benefits to Theo
especially because he had these
intolerances before
um unlike other dog food Sundays is zero
prep zero mess and zero stress it is
shelf stable which makes it easy to feed
your pup top quality food every order
ships right to your door you'll never
worry about running out of dry food
again it is also affordable it costs 40
less than other Healthy dog food brands
because they don't waste money shipping
Frozen packages instead they spend on
what matters which is sourcing the best
all-natural ingredients we worked out a
special deal for our dog loving
listeners get 35 off your first order of
Sundays go to Sundays for dogs.com toast
or just use code toast at checkout
that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash toast upgrade your pup to Sundays
and feel good about what you feed your
dog today's episode is also your dog
you're a dog your dogs are gay literally
that's a line I quote from Legally blunt
2 more than I think I quote at any
single movie In My Life
dolls are gay
yeah remember do you know what I'm
talking about
mclared I was just shocked that that's
what you quote more than any movie in
your life I find myself constantly
saying your dogs are gay I don't know
why we know that the stripes Brethren
are yeah for sure
um today's episode is also brought to
you by Jenny Kane what a better way to
kick off the new year than with a much
needed home refresh featuring
handcrafted furniture and Home Decor
from Jenny Kane you can make any home
your dream home with Jenny Kane's
Timeless and Ultra cozy pieces shopping
for home decor can be so stressful and
time consuming but Jenny Kane has
elevated style and quality that you've
been looking for from throws and pillows
to beds and nightstands Jenny King's
products are always worth the investment
and truly built to last forever find
your Forever Decor pieces with our
exclusive discount so we are getting you
15 off at Jenny Kane it's the code is
toast of course at jennycane.com
um I have so many Jenny Kane products
first of all the slippers the candles
which are on like the lower priced end
are just like a really great way to
start like freshening up your space or
walking around in your gorgeous slippers
lighting your gorgeous candles maybe
laying under your throw blanket on some
of your Jenny Kane pillows they also
have really gorgeous Furniture
um like the bed is one of a lot of her
bed designs are some of my favorite
styles there's so elegant yes Jackie did
you want to ask I just wanted to say I
just did a little bathroom refresh I got
two new bath mats from Jenny Kane I
think you could see it in the background
of my Instagram story right now and
they're so beautiful they've made my
bathroom look so classy I didn't realize
the ones that I was using were so ratty
they were like modeled from New York
with like Rats on them yeah
and I love these Shetty cane ones like
it made the biggest difference in my
bathroom find your Forever pieces at
jennycane.com home our listeners will
get 15 off your first order when you use
code toast at checkout so that's 15 off
your first order at
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e.com slash home that
promo code is toast for the new year new
you new home with Jenny Kane thank you
mclartiel you're welcome our first story
something puzzling but I'm sure we can
get to the bottom of it Selena Gomez and
Drew tagger went bowling together page
six is calling it a bowling date though
I'm still not sure Selena Gomez and Drew
Taggart seem to have confirmed their
rumored romance page six has obtained
exclusive photos of the singer actress
and The Chainsmokers member on a flirty
date at the gutter a New York City
bowling alley on Sunday an eyewitness
told Paige chicks the couple was making
out like teenagers while enjoying some
alone time there was also a group of
young girls that went up for pictures
from her shortly after and a man getting
an autograph the pair kept things casual
with Selena wearing a black sweatshirt
and matching sweatpants
I don't know that she would wear
sweatpants on a date like and so early
in their relationship and he wore a camo
shirt and dark pants
so yesterday I was like fully of the
mind that this was false US Weekly is
not reliable this is never happening and
now we have proof and I know Jackie's
going to choose to continue to live in
denial I will accept that they are
probably dating I don't think it's going
to last forever but I was wrong I
literally could not see it being true
and now I've actually physically seen it
and it's important to acknowledge when
you're wrong I just want to say
I'm holding out still because one these
two are bowling and then they have all
these pictures of them but they say they
were making out all over each other but
there's not one picture of them making
out but someone across the room is
taking pictures of them the entire time
if they were making out would there not
be one photo of it
true
I think per I'm gonna stick with what I
said yesterday I think that they're
working on a song and I think that this
is creating hype for the song and it's
like okay our PR person is making us go
bowling together like there's worse
things I know I just feel like Selena's
above that like she doesn't do PR
relationships you know she doesn't
really do relationships she hasn't right
honestly I feel like PR relationships
kind of get a bad rap like they're the
worst fakest thing but it's like okay
I'm not gonna it doesn't have to be like
we have to pretend and like get married
and have kids but it's like oh you want
us to just be seen bowling together to
help our song like we're not we're not
lying and saying we're dating we're just
gonna like go out and have a good time
that's fine okay so if in the next year
we get a song with like The Chainsmokers
slash Drew and Selena Gomez we will know
that this was fraudulent but if we don't
and they don't last forever and we never
hear about them again they did they went
on on a date
I don't think she would wear that on a
date
I don't think Selena gives a [ __ ]
honestly I know but like
if you're in like the that's not a date
outfit sorry
it's not black sweatshirt and black
sweatpants but it is bowling like you
don't want to wear your finest to the
but to the alley it's true but you know
what it is it's a studio outfit
oh my God is she wrong you guys know I I
don't think I've said anything incorrect
so far so no you're using your critical
thinking skills I'm very impressed I am
and of course that you know what if I'm
wrong about this I'll honestly be happy
because like I want Selena to find love
I wanted to be with someone who's like
successful and in the industry rather
than like you know some mysterious
businessman who we don't know like I
want to know who Selena's with so like
I'll get on the ship if it's true I just
like I don't believe that the ship is
setting sail
there are also like a lot of shady
things coming out about Drew in terms of
timeline like he was dating Steve Jobs's
daughter Eve jobs which I'll never get
over that that's her name
um up until like a few days before this
rumor came out and they had like broken
up but it was like very much like we
still need to talk and like very much
not completely broken
um she had recently even posted a photo
of them on Instagram and then when this
rumor came out she deleted the photo and
deleted her Instagram
that's like hella dramatic like you
didn't do anything wrong and he looks
like an ass like you actually look like
a nice girl like leave your Instagram up
Eve maybe okay this piece doesn't add up
to me because that sounds maybe she's in
on it too no no I don't think she would
be in on it because like she's oh my God
you scared the [ __ ] out of me oh my God
I literally I'm not okay hi
are you are you from
oh he told me you were coming tomorrow
yeah okay well I can't do right now I'm
sorry
I mean you're more than welcome to do
your thing
I'm recording if you could just not
behind me you can hit the radiator the
radiator's not in frame
oh my God I'm not okay Pest Control is
here no Pest Control is so important we
love Pest Control let this be a message
to all of our listeners call the
Exterminator you gotta get that [ __ ]
done once a month and I really recommend
sayonara they're great
awesome okay so let me give you my
theory on this because to me this sounds
like this eve jobs piece is the only
thing that doesn't add up because it
does sound like she would be like upset
that he moved on so quickly and so she
deleted her Instagram dramatically but I
think it's because she doesn't want any
part of like the Selena stands on her
Instagram you know what and she was
she's wise for that she doesn't want to
be mixed up with these two and like in a
romance uh
love triangle look how it works for
Haley Bieber Eve said no so true like
and it's not Selena's fault but she does
and can have like a very toxic fan base
and it's very possible like she just
wanted to you know write herself out of
this narrative one in which she never
asked to be a part of yeah so I like
that that would explain that part and it
still leaves it open to this being a PR
relationship or a real relationship
yeah hmm that's good no so far you've
been able to explain all this away I
still feel like they probably went out
on a date even though you're right like
so the person was taking pictures but
not of them making out but they were
making out like teenagers no it's so
important to question everything and
like Celine there were a bunch of girls
out that were Selena fans if they saw
her making out like they would have
videos and photos
no Selena is too famous to be making out
with someone in public and not there be
a photo of it especially when there are
photos of the two of them at the same
event like five minutes earlier right
people with camera phones were there no
you're 100 right question everything
this is really this is some fine
investigative work Jackie like I'm
really I'm very impressed thank you so I
think that if they want us to leave it
they have to take it up a notch but I
don't think Selena would resort to like
publicly making out with someone who
like she's actually not interested in
but like to go bowling sure whatever
right between jam sessions everybody
likes to bowl
everybody makes mistakes you just said
everybody just like Hannah
oh my God that's so kind of you oh
speaking of Hannah
I had heard this before yesterday's
episode but I didn't know if it was true
or not so I didn't want to say it on the
show and then I we got some feedback um
from yesterday A lot of the stuff that's
coming out about Miley song like when I
was your man is the song that Liam
dedicated she filmed in the house that
they used to whatever he had dated 14
girls a lot of that was like [ __ ] made
up by Miley stands to like make the song
go viral and like
give it like some drama like a lot of
[ __ ] is not true
um just want to say that all worked on
me definitely gave the song relevance
right
I guess yeah how would we know that he
cheated on her with 14 people in that
house like also the suit uh yeah okay
out here making stuff up honestly we
need the Miley stands working for us
yeah no the Miley stands like doing more
marketing and strategy than like the
biggest record labels in the in the
country yeah
good for that I thought that was
interesting yeah good for them and you
know what if this is what's going on
with Selena then I'm happy for her but
it's so important to constantly be
asking questions exactly are you ready
for our next story yes
Todd and Julie Chrisley report to prison
to begin serving their time for tax
fraud Todd and Julie Chrisley are
beginning their new lives behind bars
the Chrisley Knows Best couple reported
to their respective federal prisons on
Tuesday two months after they were
sentenced to a combined 19 years for
fraud and tax evasion respective like
they're in different I know like you
would keep men and women separate but
yeah separate
damn Todd is serving 12 years at federal
prison camp Pensacola in Florida
meanwhile Julie was originally set to
spend the next seven years at Federal
Correction Institution Mariana just two
hours away but she was reassigned to
Federal FMC Lexington in Kentucky
well Todd's is called a camp I mean I
know it's probably still not great but
okay it's called Camp I mean who knows
what that is it one of those like no the
federal color I don't think so actually
hold on how would I find that out I
don't know we'd have to let's see we'd
have to see who else is there federal
prison like where's galane
yeah or like where did uh Felicity
Huffman go I'm sorry Chrisley serving
his time in one of America's cushiest
prisons okay
it's still a prison like let's be real
it's minimum security
labeled one of the cushiest in America
usually reserved for white-collar Crime
that includes wire fraud mail fraud and
Health Care fraud okay but um what about
Julie's
Julie was federally sounded bad Federal
FMC Lexington
reminds me of the book horse
uh
oh her first dinner in prison revealed I
can't with these are oh my God how do
they know that they must like look at
the menu I don't know
she
didn't come up as like a cushy place
no but this doesn't mean it's not I
imagine it's similar
um because they have the same level of
crime
so are they never going to be able to
see each other because like it's not
like you can visit your spouse in prison
if you're in prison
I guess not that's like so sad yeah like
I know they did that [ __ ]
this seems so harsh
yeah it really does
it's such a long time like with Jen Shaw
like I could see I could see what my
life in six years yeah I cannot see my
life in 12 years yeah agreed so it's 12
and seven
yeah she got seven he got twelve which
means his like involvement was more but
he got to go to the cushy Camp I hope
she gets to go that's just because there
was an article calling it a cushy prison
like I right there might be this might
be cushy well I guess yeah because she
is right
like that cushy prison that Jeffrey
Epstein was in where they like let him
go home for a few hours every day oh
really is that where he was literally
like he got turned into his house for a
few hours every day maybe to sleep at
night God go to prison but he was in
Florida okay and Todd's is in Florida
or um
but not the prison where he was found in
no no
um he had served time yes before prior
yeah
um
let's see
it was a facility in Florida I'm really
curious if it's the same one as Chrisley
I don't think I'll find it in time okay
um well regardless I'm wishing them well
strength faith
yeah that's all you can do
agreed are you ready for our next story
I am I guess it's technically some more
Selena news because only murders in the
building has revealed their new cast
member for season three and it's Meryl
Streep the show is so elegant season
three of only murders at Hulu the
announcement was made by series star
Selena in a video posted to Instagram
which can be seen in this article it is
not yet known whether Street will appear
in a guest recurring or series regular
capacity true that so Paul Rudd is also
like a series regular for this third
season Meryl Streep I don't know if
she's ever done television like this
show is so elevated I feel like we don't
really live in the type of world anymore
where TV was like kind of beneath a lot
of actors like I think some of the
biggest and baddest will do TV now even
like you know movie stars but I don't
think Meryl Streep ever has I feel like
this is a really big deal well she did
Big Little Lies oh yeah and a couple
other mini series that's true that's
true thank you for correcting me
um
what you're saying like one it's still
major for her it's major for her it's
major for the show but the show is
extremely star-studded and elevated I'm
sure like Martin and Steven Slater have
like rolodexes of context and people who
want to be involved in the show because
it's such a big hit I wonder why we've
never had a tailor Cameo like just for
like a second
Taylor definitely loves the show
I feel like Taylor wouldn't want to make
it about her that's true that's true you
know like let's leaner have her thing
no that's so fair
yeah and like every Cameo there's not
just been like stars for star's sake
like Jane Lynch was on
um car delivering but then Amy Schumer
they had rolls yeah no you're right
except for sting
yeah and a little bit Amy Schumer like
her I don't really understand her
part at all yeah
but I know what you mean like it's more
than just a cameo it's like more
purposeful yeah so I feel like Meryl
Streep's not gonna be like a main
character but she will have a role in
this somewhere that's very exciting I
love that show like second season like
it got away from me a little bit but I
still enjoyed it like it's still such a
good show the writing is so funny Martin
Short and Steve Martin are so funny it's
a great show it is and I think what it
underscores is the power of podcasting
I agree and I think that's so important
so important
but it's power of True Crime podcasting
which is not your fave
no it's not that it's not my fave I just
don't think they belong in the comedy
category and I think that's not a crazy
thing to say
yeah
Am I Wrong
um there's literally a true crime
category yeah yeah no I hear what you're
saying I I do
yeah are you ready for our next story
yeah it's a little Bond trap news excuse
me the Von traps you know him yeah from
The Sound of Music yep the famed Sound
of Music Von Trapp family is developing
a TV drama show wait I'm sorry the Von
traps are still alive I know that was
shocking to me too but at least like
there and wait Descendants the Von traps
are real yeah
that was their story fleeing the Nazis
okay
can I just share something
sure
I don't think I've ever seen The Sound
of Music
I don't think you've ever seen The Sound
of Music where you've been old enough to
understand it
no like I've definitely seen the Vin
Diesel movie pacifier where that kid is
in the local community production of the
Von traps and he sings you are 16 going
on 17. I definitely know that but they
you know before they know he's doing
community theater he's got a Nazi
costume in his room and they're worried
about him becoming a skinhead such a
good movie by the way I've never seen I
don't I'm telling you I've never seen
the sound of music I think
those are alive with the sound of music
never seen it I think that we saw it
when we were younger we were just too
young to understand and then I more
recently saw that Carrie Underwood live
version because she played uh the
governess what's her name in the library
Julie Andrews in the NBC version for NBC
live like you know how they do live
things yeah she was in it so can you
just give me like really quickly what's
the synopsis of the film I know the
Nazis are involved and I know there's a
bunch of kids who sing so there's a
bunch of kids who saying they have this
like amazing governess I need to
remember her name are the Von traps
Jewish they don't sound Jewish and
that's kind of a Flawless
right that's the part doesn't add up so
why would they be escaping the Nazis if
they're just a bunch of like Germans I
don't think it's a great place to be
okay you know especially a Nazi
privy to these crimes yeah amazing call
um so there are a bunch of kids I think
they're like a little unruly so they
have a governess and she like shows them
the power of music and the hills were
alive with the sound of music teaches
them Doremi and they're just like
singing and [ __ ] around and then the
Nazis come and they have to leave
do they successfully get out yeah
because now they're New York City based
and they're writing a drama series so
the Von trap descendants are currently
living in Manhattan yes uh miles is the
New York city-based grandson of George's
eldest child Rupert who was actually
depicted as Lisa in the oscar-winning
1966 movie and miles is the one who is
developing this scripted drama called
the baroness
it's going its build as being a mixture
of the crown and This Is Us
excuse me like that's the vibe I I kind
of hear what they're saying like those
are the two shows that couldn't have
less in common it's gonna be the crown
like historical but like corny as hell
this is this sounds turned like really
it's like it sounds like it's gonna be
bad I don't know I like the title I like
the title too the baroness
uh it sounds like it would be on like
the History Channel
yeah for sure I'm trying to read what a
synopsis of the movie's about but it
literally just says like the governess
Maria teaching them the power of music
and oh and and the father is a widowed
Naval Captain I think there's a romance
between Julie Andrews and the dad yeah
and then there's seven children and
brings a new love of life and music into
the home
then World War II
doe a deer a female deer
hooray a drop of Golden Sun me a name I
call myself far along the way to run so
a needle pulling thread
a note to follow so
tea a drink with jam and bread wait let
me ask you a question did that Limerick
like exist before the sound of music or
they made that [ __ ] up I think they made
that [ __ ] up
okay and then is that other song also
from The Sound of Music
these are a few of my favorite things
and whiskers on kittens yeah yeah
and I have like PTSD from that song
because that was like a classic song and
we had to practice for piano back in the
day so it was so [ __ ] hard and like I
literally hated that song because of it
I think that's why I kind of like have
like a like a hate for the sound of
music that I couldn't now like pinpoint
until now why I have a love for the
sound of music because I think I sing or
play or listen to do re me every single
day now since Harry like all of his
music like those musical toys that they
have for babies that have like five
notes yeah we can play Do-Re-Mi so yeah
that's always fun and then I listen to
the full version and oh it's Claude it's
chock full of study it's chock full of
fun which version do you listen to Julie
Andrews
um she pops off pops she pops her [ __ ]
she put her whole [ __ ] in that song she
put her up the whole [ __ ] in the movie
and I now honestly I want to watch a
movie because we love a movie musical
Julie put her whole and juicy in that in
that film
she really really did love that for her
uh anyways
I'm gonna be open to this because if I
if I didn't know the story and I went on
Netflix and I saw there's a a show
called The baroness
click yeah you would watch that well I
just am here for this story because I
feel like that was something I was like
kind of embarrassed of like I feel like
it's like a woman of a certain age and
like a Jewish woman like I should know
what the sound of music is and like I've
never like had the opportunity to ask
and now I did no I think there's there's
definitely something that's confusing
how it's about like music and education
like Nazis and Nazis I totally agree
yeah and honestly I feel as though if it
weren't for the amazing film The
Pacifier with Vin Diesel like I really
wouldn't know half the [ __ ] that I knew
up until this moment about that film
that's beautiful that movie is so good
star studded too Lauren Graham Vin
Diesel
I love it
um oh and Rogers and Hammerstein did the
music for Sound of Music so of course it
popped off that's how you know it's like
legit yeah yeah okay maybe I'll check it
out again and um we'll see you in the
baroness comes out yep for a full
roasting of this is a sex crown
are you ready for our fifth and final
story already yeah it's little Shakira
drama I am keeping up okay so Shakira is
going through a divorce with her
ex-husband because he she discovered
that she cheated on him and there was
like oh no he cheated on her I'm sorry
that's what I meant he cheated on her
and there's all of these things that
like she's doing and the mother-in-law's
house and like a witch on the balcony
yeah on the balcony but she took aim at
him in her new music video where there's
a severed head in her fridge of her
ex-husband and uh we find out how she
discovered he was cheating on her did
you hear this no okay so Shakira
reportedly discovered her ex's Affair by
finding a clue hidden in their fridge
the singer who split oh yes sorry I did
hear this from the footballer in June
after 11 years together realized her ex
was having an affair when she discovered
a jar of strawberry jam had been eaten
while she was away so she said that um
or it's known that and no one in the
help no one else in the family liked the
jam that was in the fridge and she went
away and came back and the jam had been
fully I just want to say like the fault
in this story is like why would you keep
a container of gem in your house that
nobody in your family likes that you
like that's Shakira like the gym yeah
yeah I think so so it's like it's
Shakira's jam and like if she's the only
one who would eat it yeah that's I mean
that's super sleuthy and that's not
something that her husband would know to
like to think of to get rid of yeah so
that's crazy no and by the way it's one
thing to be like [ __ ] another woman
but it's another for the woman to be in
your house going through your fridge
like that's like a relationship using
your jam like yeah making herself toast
like if it was just like a one-time
thing like you probably wouldn't [ __ ] at
your own house and she definitely
wouldn't be going through the kitchen
looking for you know snacks in the
middle of the night yeah
it's in her house yeah that's what I'm
saying I would also love for like
Shakira to come out of this with like a
smucker sponsorship you know or whatever
brand it was yeah I was trying to look
at the brand it it doesn't look like a
brand but it does kind of look similar
to Bon Maman
yeah but also what where does Shakira
live I don't think she lives in America
it could be like an international brand
right well Batman is international and
do you know that they hid Jews in their
Factory during the Holocaust I did know
that about the bonamon
um
gym it's like the jam that has the cap
that looks like a picnic table like
that's what this Shakira jam looks like
so it's like there was no label
I'm sure one of her kids peeled it off
it also kind of looks like something
like a jam oh man made herself that is
[ __ ] up if she made that [ __ ] by
herself with the preservers
preservatives and everything yeah
we tell the Bon mama and Holocaust story
again oh I mean there was this meme go
not a meme but anything that's text on
an Instagram I call him yeah but there
was this card going around
um like the bonamon factory I guess it's
in France it sounds French during the
Holocaust say in the factory
[Music]
which is really beautiful it is and like
I'm Smucker's loyal but ever since then
I pick up a bowl mama and every now and
then I support smackers is like a little
too sugary nice but this is for children
it's fraudulent yeah I actually buy
intentionally and because I like it
thought my mom I know I just like cannot
get enough of that strawberry preserves
from Smuckers it's so sugary it's so
good like it's [ __ ] crack on a
[ __ ] like warm corn muffin that's
probably what Shakira's family likes
let me give you the good stuff yeah yeah
totally she cracked the case but I do
think you have to suspect your husband
in order to notice it like that a
hundred percent because also like if you
ask me right now like how much is left
in your ketchup bottle I would have no
[ __ ] idea yeah and like I also live
in a vacuum of things in my house that
only I eat actually I do have like
there's a lot of things like that yeah
like my Fiber One bars
but I would have just your favorite
members I would have just assumed
I don't know sometimes actually clears
out the fridge
company except Jam doesn't expire but
anyways no for Shakira it's a it's a
good it's good work good investigative
work on her part but you're right she
had to know something was up in order to
be like looking for details this small
yeah in order like if I saw a jam that
was eaten and it was the only thing that
I eat in the house and other people
don't I wouldn't be like my husband's
cheating on me no I would be like oh I
must have been eating it in the middle
of the night again or you're like oh
maybe the ship Heroes came over Kayla
wanted PB and Jay wow yeah like I don't
know I know where my mind wouldn't go
there either
um well those were great stories thanks
Jack so much and don't fret the show is
not over because it is Wednesday and we
have deer toasters Our advice segment so
if you ever want to write in and get
your thing read on air we will always
keep it Anonymous so you will always
read your thing
you think
um and the email is deertoesters
gmail.com try and keep it brief need to
know information only we can't be
reading you know essays here on the show
and again your identity is never going
to be compromised because we don't care
so you know
um dear toasters is brought to you by
Legacy box Legacy box is a super simple
mail-in service to have all of your
videotapes camcorder tapes film reels
old pictures converted to perfectly
preserved digital files Legacy box is
the industry leader and has helped over
a million customers Safeguard their past
it is the simplest way to preserve your
precious memories and check off a New
Year's resolution Legacy box is hands
down the brand I get the most DMS about
like what was that company called what
was the Legacy box code listen up okay
here's the code it's toast it's
legacybox.com toast okay
legacybox.com
toast Legacy box is the digital
preservation service old VHS tapes
camcorder film reels photos you have
lying around we did it years ago it was
one of the best things we ever did first
of all it's so easy they send you the
packaging they send you the label and
then you sit back and you get emails you
know every every time they update the
progress of your box you get an email it
arrived or it's being processed or we're
shipping it to you now it was so easy I
think in total I got like maybe 10
emails
um I felt very safe I knew they would
come back to me Legacy box is everything
of the sort now if you've been wanting
to do it it's legacybox.com toast
legacybox.com toast take advantage of
the exclusive offer
and like just do it because your family
will thank you and it's time it's time
stop putting that off like that box of
crap collection collecting dust in your
basement or your storage get rid of it
send it to Legacy box and they will give
you a thumb drive however you want it we
got it on a thumb drive I felt that was
the easiest way and it was really
stunning really it was one of the best
things we ever did
today's episode is also brought to you
by rocket money formerly known as true
bill is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels unwanted subscriptions
monitors or spending helps lower your
bills all in one place over 80 percent
of people have subscriptions that they
forget about like that streaming service
you bought to watch just one episode or
that free trial you never even used
rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones you
don't want rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as the click of a
button simply find the subscription you
don't want press cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you no more long hold
times with customer service or tedious
emailing back and forth over 3 million
people have used rocket money they save
the average person up to 720 a year so
say goodbye to last year's outdated
disorganized methods of managing your
money and say hello to Rocket money
hello hello
the better way to hack your finances in
2023 stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com toast that's rocket
money.com slash toast
r-o-c-k-e-t-m-o-n-e-y.com slash toast
love it all right ready for some dare
toasters yep
tear Jackson Claude first of all I just
want to say how much my friends and I
love you guys we use your advice like
our Bible LOL I'm in a bit of a
predicament and I want the advice of
some beautiful stunning and smart girls
I've been dating my P John boyfriend for
five years we're planning on getting
engaged in the upcoming year we don't
live together yet but we are more than
ready to sign a lease with each other in
the next few months
right before we plan on getting engaged
the problem is my parents are extremely
traditional they've expressed many times
how disappointed they would be if I
lived with someone before we were
married they love my boyfriend so much
and they want us to be married but I
don't have the same views on as them and
I want to live with him before marriage
my question is do I live with my
boyfriend before we are engaged married
and possibly start our marriage out on a
bad note with my parents but we'd be
setting boundaries now that I will make
my own decisions or do I go against what
we both want see for ourselves just to
please my parents thanks so much for
your help I love you both P.S my
boyfriend is extremely patient and has
put the ball in my court but is willing
to have difficult combos with my parents
if need be sincerely a toaster who loves
her parents and her man and who's in a
predicament
I don't know they've been together for
five years I I will say like I'm coming
at this from you know a more
conservative POV like I didn't live with
Ben until we were engaged yeah that was
something like that I was told had to be
done but also something like I was down
for like that's just how that was like a
rule in our house yeah and I agree with
it I feel like if you can
wait to move into with him until you're
engaged like that's kind of meeting your
parents halfway and also be like being
modern and being true to yourself but it
sounds like you're about to get engaged
in the next few months and you're about
to move in together in the next few
months like I think that would also kind
of put a fire under your boyfriend's but
they kind of need like
these like benchmarks that like okay we
have to be engaged by this time or else
like we can't move in together and like
logistically that becomes a cluster [ __ ]
I think the idea of
waiting till you're engaged moving
together is nice I know it's not for
everyone I know a lot of people feel
like you should get to know your partner
and how they live before you agree to
marry them
um I think if you've been with someone
for five years I'm sure you spend a lot
of time at his place and vice versa like
I I didn't feel like I was spending so
many much time over at Zach's when we
were dating I didn't learn anything new
about him when we moved in together like
I had technically like known his living
habits so I don't know how much I agree
with that but there are other things
aside from you know how sloppy he is
like then you're paying bills together
and like that just shows you another
side of your partner which I think to
wait until you're married
would be really hard but I think if you
can tell your parents like I understand
where you guys are coming from we're
gonna wait till we get engaged I think
that would be a happy medium and that's
also something that like I think
is nice yeah it's smart and then also
like then you'll get engaged like right
no for sure I think your parents
expectation of not wanting you to live
with someone until you get married like
that's extreme like if you're engaged to
someone like you can live with them
um and I know some people are probably
gonna like really disagree with this
like because many many people live have
very happy relationships and they live
with their Partners long before they get
engaged and I'm just saying speaking
from my own experience and it sounds
like this girl maybe has like raised in
a similar way
um I think it's totally reasonable for
you to do whatever you want but I do
think like a really happy medium for you
for your parents and for your boyfriend
is just to wait till you get engaged to
move in together it sounds like that
isn't that crazy your parents would be
okay with that and then also you know
you're engaged and and it's it's a lot
less stressful to like go in with
someone like on finances and bills in a
house when you're engaged so yeah that's
just us being conservative but that's
like low-key like we're very traditional
we are and I think that that's nice but
it's also more modern because it's not
like you're waiting until tomorrow
you're married also I just wanted to say
one more thing about it but now I can't
remember but I understand that there's
going to be people who like totally
disagree with us like live with your
boyfriend of course and and I'm like if
that's what works for you like no but it
also depends on what's your relationship
with your parents like some people oh
that's what I mean the older you get
like really don't really listen to their
parents anymore and some people like
always maintain that level of like
authority of with their parents in their
life it also just totally depends on
what your relationship with your parents
is like if you like if you listen to
them and like that's something you want
to continue to like it's it just depends
yeah that's what I was gonna say she
said like do you think we should put our
foot down now and show them like we're
not going to be living like the way that
we want they want us to live but I feel
like once you get married like that's
you're more of you know an adult you're
your own person as opposed to you know
it's very traditional tool from like
your parents house and then you're
married but like then you guys are
making choices as a married couple I
think to like let them know now we're
putting our foot you can't tell us what
to do just like for that for the sake of
it you can you can plant your flag in
the ground on something else when you
need to like I don't think just because
you listen to them halfway on this
doesn't mean they expect you to do what
they say for the rest of your life yeah
agreed
um okay so this next one is the one I
feel personally invested in and like
kind of offended by and like I'm kind of
gonna drag this girl who wrote it
hi Jackson Claude I really need your
advice my boyfriend and I are on the
brink of being engaged and I could not
be happier he's the man of my dreams and
I can't wait to be his wife I only have
one concern his parents the four of us
just went on a long trip together and I
couldn't help but notice how much they'd
bicker it was happening multiple times
on a daily basis and it was extremely
uncomfortable whenever I'd look over to
my boyfriend to see his reaction he
didn't even Flinch it's very obvious
that this is normal behavior for them
and my boyfriend has been used to it for
years
if not his whole life I have extreme
anxiety and this that this would that
this is what he would expect our
marriage to be like my parents rarely
bicker or fight in front of me and my
siblings so I'm not really sure how to
handle this environment I obviously know
that they fight but they do it behind
closed doors which is how I'd like to
behave in my future marriage how do I
talk to my boyfriend about this it's
gotten to the point where I've gone
completely silent at dinner when we're
with his parents and they're bickering
because my anxiety's through the roof I
don't want to offend him or make him
think I don't love his family it's such
a sensitive topic and I'm really scared
he will not be open to the conversation
please help I want to be open to the
conversation [ __ ] just literally none
of your business like first of all
like now you being judgmental of like a
40-year marriage like right let's take a
seat take a seat okay second of all like
once again I'm out here like constantly
trying to change the narrative when it
comes to bickering like bickering is
normal you know what the Shapiro say
they say Pickering is a form of
communication it is it's also a love
language like yeah I told you guys that
I recorded an uh an episode
when I was in LA an interview with
someone who's like very um
like legit I didn't say who it was but
whatever we did a whole segment on
relationships and I said to him like
I've never been
like self-conscious about me and Ben's
bickering like it's always been funny
and like it's really how we communicate
but ever since you know we started this
podcast and then he would come on like
people would give a [ __ ] for it like I
started to feel like maybe I'm like
being a [ __ ] and he really made me feel
so good about it he was like literally
like fighting a relationship where you
don't fight you don't exist like it's
not real so first of all I think you're
being really judgmental of like someone
else's marriage especially like it's
literally none of your business no and
especially like grown older people like
I hate when younger people tell older
people how to act and it's like talking
after a 40-year marriage exactly yeah I
also think bickering in public is
healthier than like
hiding it in general I think just like
if you you have nothing to hide like
it's probably better than someone who's
hiding something yeah my overall
takeaway from this is like why do you
care you know you're about to get
engaged it should be like the happiest
time of your life like you're you're
doing about something that has literally
nothing to do with you it doesn't really
affect your life like if you get
uncomfortable by it at dinners all right
so you have an uncomfortable dinner with
your in-laws once a month right you
don't have dinner every night together
right I don't understand why so much of
your energy is being put towards these
two people the only thing that I would
say like I could understand where she's
coming from it's like she's worried that
that's how he will approach
relationships because that's what he's
seen which I think is very fair I think
a lot of people you know they see
something at home and then they repeat
it um but then that's on you to like
four to different paths with your
husband and like bigger bickering is a
two-way street so like if you're not
bickering with him like there will be no
bickering but see that's a conversation
worth having just being like you know
expressing concern about like how you
two will communicate as opposed to being
like your parents are bickering and I'm
uncomfortable like you just sound like a
distressed millennial
yeah but I also think like I think it's
easy for people at the outset of
marriage to be like we're not gonna
bicker we're gonna solve our problems
you know we're gonna it's very
Fantastical good luck with that and then
like seriously I want to hear from them
in 40 years I'm going to set a timer on
my phone for 40 years I'm gonna write
her back and say what do you think about
bickering yeah no I just think this is
like a naive point of view and I really
would encourage you like not to waste
your time and energy on this like this
is supposed to be like a beautiful time
in your life focus on your man like
you're thinking way too much about your
in-laws and how they communicate hey
it's none of your business and be like
you aren't like affected by it like and
just focus that energy on steering your
relationship outside of the bickering
Zone if that's really important to you
and you don't like that Dynamic which I
do get that especially if she did not
grow up with it yeah
um and maybe it's you know like Adrian
and Paul that to me is just like when
bickering goes too far so yes whatever
imagine her in laws are Adrian and Paul
like no yeah and that's and that's
really uncomfortable but it's not your
problem like not even in the slightest
yeah so I would just focus on showing
your husband a better way yeah
if you don't like it don't do it
um okay ready for our last one yep my
Queens so I recently rekindled things
with this guy from a few years ago
when we first started talking he told me
he was fresh off of a breakup we've now
been dating a few months but something
has felt off me being a little skeptical
and curious I asked my friend to follow
his ex on her fin stuff because she's
private I'm new to this creeping thing
we found his ex we got her to accept the
request and realize that they are not
only still together but they live
together and also just celebrated three
years what do I do I only know he's
cheating on her because I use this fake
account do I DM her for my real account
the fake account how do I confront him
I'm going to come across as a crazy
[ __ ] for having used a fake account to
stalk her to get this information help
sincerely a toaster who will be ending
things but like how do I go about this
okay so the man she's seeing for three
months who told her he like went through
a breakup has actually still been with
the girl and is actually engaged to the
girl I mean she's gonna break up with
him but does she tell the girl
I don't know what my philosophy on this
is you know My Philosophy is Right
Anonymous letter
no because an anonymous letter like
do you want to ask someone it's
incredible questions it's not credible
it's not credible you have more
questions it's not just something you're
going to take at face value it could be
explained away like he could be like you
know I have these crazy ex-girlfriends
like right it could be explained away
and you're not there to defend
like I I don't I need to decide what I
think is like the right thing to do in
these situations Girl Code
or mind your own goddamn business not
your [ __ ] problem
but I would want to know
[ __ ] you you can't you got to tell her
like it's just a yeah something I'm
gonna go with what I would want I would
want to know
what are you yes especially oh my God
you're not engaged like they're not
married yet they don't have kids like
they're on the precipice like it's not
too late I so now it's how does she tell
her
um
follow her from your own account
follow her own account have her accept
it and be like you could also send her a
message without following her yeah
but send proof be like I am shook I just
found this out I was like stalking you
not to be a freak but because I had like
a feeling I had a suspicion like and
I've found out that you guys are
literally engaged and still together you
never broke up and I think you should
know we've been dating for the last
three months here's pictures of us from
last week I have nothing to gain from
this I am breaking up with him I just
wanted you to know because I see that
you're engaged and what she wants to do
with that information you can't make
someone see the truth what you want to
do with that information is her business
but you did the right thing and you can
bow out peacefully agreed
yeah you got to tell her follow her be
direct it's time yeah
yeah no I I often struggle between like
what's the right thing to do and like
what's my business
yeah
but this is both yeah
yeah they say I think telling her 100 I
don't see a reason why you shouldn't
tell her same
same
um well thank you to everyone who wrote
in and got vulnerable with us sorry some
of you had to hear the hard truth
um that email account is deertoesters
gmail.com please if you've been thinking
about writing in right in I feel like
um we're almost at like the bottom of
the email so like yeah dear toasters
gmail.com
that's our show
that's our show we have another show
coming up tonight so 5 PM we'll see you
guys there more toast if you want us to
Frank some Fred with you then head over
to patreon.com the toast you will get
the link at five o'clock for our live
show and Jackson Claude will be popping
off you never know what's gonna happen
and I think of course you can watch it
afterwards if you can't of course sign
on at five o'clock but I think it'll be
really fun for those of us who are we're
in this together
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
on Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio
I get rid of cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an incredible
Wednesday don't forget to hump someone
you love and we'll see you tomorrow you
know what's going to be incredib when
you see Maverick in Paris 100 love you
bye